[Music]  only choose truth Tyler um your love  triangle between Olivia Marquis and you  it's not connected in any way with  Sophia's actually I mean really yeah  they fell in love and during the roof  sequence I'm pretty sure there's like a  whole roof she was like oh my gosh oh it  happened  yeah yeah I definitely had a lot of fun  on that roof with her but didn't really  acknowledge it until afterward we all  took a trip with each other and then  that's when like things started to like  click two girls it wasn't even shooting  the moon no no totally platonic and  friends and really good friends and we  really are like buddies you guys are  like the same person I've never met two  people who are more perfect for you oh  it's really great what what dare me to  hurt ya cuz she a queen  you actually beat me to Sofia I was like  gonna ask her out but like Tyler beat me  to see yeah I you know I am happy in  life  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]